entre llamas y con mucho descontento así
terminó Lima tras una nueva jornada de
protestas contra el gobierno la conocida
como la gran marcha de los cuatro suyos
compuesta por organizaciones civiles
provenientes del sur como con
manifestaciones en varios puntos de la
capital Su objetivo era llegar al
palacio de gobierno y al congreso para
forzar la dimisión del gobierno pero la
represión policial no lo permitió con un
operativo de casi 12.000 policías contra
los manifestantes
reprimir al pueblo hoy nuestros hermanos
han decidido de venir acá a Lima
metropolitana para demostrarnos Cómo se
protege al Perú Cómo se salva el Perú
Cómo se cuida la democracia y cómo se
lucha por ellos a pesar de que aún no se
han investigado las causas del incendio
una vecina testigo sostuvo que fue
ocasionado por una bomba en lacrimógena
de la policía algo que el gobierno ha
negado acusando a los manifestantes de
malos ciudadanos y de intentar quebrar
el estado de derecho y a la par Llamando
al diálogo el gobierno está firme y su
ga
más Unido que nunca nuevamente
llamó al diálogo
llamo a la calma las manifestaciones en
el sur fueron muy diferentes allí a
diferencia de la capital la policía sí
usó armas de fuego en Arequipa un hombre
murió tras recibir un balazo en el
abdomen y se sumó a las más de 50
víctimas desde el inicio de las
protestas en diciembre
nos estás pagando con balas no estás
pagando con muertos a nuestros hijos a
nuestros hermanos en medio del caos El
Ejecutivo de Perú declaró estado de
emergencia por 30 días en los estados de
Amazonas libertad y tacna que se suman a
puno cusco Lima y callao todo mientras
se busca una vía de diálogo que acabe
con este descontento en el país